if we look at the existentialists
or even like uh modern philosopher
psychologist types like jordan peterson
i'm not sure if you're familiar with it
i know jordan pretty well
we go way back actually if he were here
with us today we would
he would be jumping in and i believe
very interesting and important ways but
yeah we go back
30 years ago he was basically saying our
work
is nonsense let's get into this i'm sure
i'll talk to jordan
uh eventually on this thing yeah going
through some rough times right now
oh absolutely and i and i wish him well
um
jordan was working on his maps of
meaning
and we were publishing our work
and i think jordan at the time
um was concerned about
our vague claims to the effect that
all meaning is arbitrary
he takes a more jungian
as well as evolutionary view that i
don't think is wrong by the way
which is that um there are certain
kinds of meanings
that are more important let's say
religious
types and that we didn't pay sufficient
attention to that
um in our early days so uh can you try
to
uh lose a day like what his world view
is because he's also a religious man
uh so what uh what was this what was
some of the interesting aspects of the
disagreements that then
yeah well back in the day i just said
you know jordan was a young punk uh we
were young punks he was
just kind of flailing in an animated way
at some conferences saying that
um we you're still both kind of punks
yeah we have
kind of punks so i saw him three or four
years ago we spoke on a it was an
awesome day we were in canada
at uh the ontario shakespeare festival
where we were asked
to be on a canadian broadcast system
program
i think we were talking about macbeth
from a
psychodynamic perspective and i hadn't
seen him in a ton of years and we spent
two days together
had a great time you know we had just
written our book
uh the worm at the core and he's like
you know you you're
you're missing a big opportunity every
time you say something
you have to have your phone yeah and you
have to film yourself and then you have
to put it on youtube
yeah he was onto something that uh you
know just
as a small tangent yeah uh it's
it's almost sad to look at jordan
peterson somebody like yourself
after having done this podcast i've
realized that there is
really brilliant people in this world
and oftentimes
especially like when they're um uh
i mean with love are a little bit like
punks that's right
they they kind of do their own thing and
like the world doesn't
know they exist as much as they should
and it's so interesting because most
people
are kind of boring
yes and then the interesting ones kind
of go on their own and there's not a
smartphone
that's that's so interesting he was onto
something that um
i mean it's interesting that he i don't
think he was thinking from a money
perspective
but he was probably thinking of like
connecting with people or sharing his
knowledge
but uh people don't often think that way
that's right so
maybe we can try to get back to you
you're both brilliant
people and i would love to get some
interesting disagreements
earlier and later about in your
psychological work in your world views
well our disagreements
today would be uh
along two dimensions uh one is he is
and again i wish he was here to correct
me
yes um when i say that he is more
committed to the virtues of the
judeo-christian tradition
particularly christianity and in a sense
is a contemporary kierkegaard of sorts
when he's saying there's only one way
to leap into faith and
i would take ardent issue with that
claim on the grounds that that is one
but by no means
not the only way uh
to find meaning and value in life
and so and i see his
what's his warm at the core what is like
uh so
we're talking about a little bit of a
higher level of discovering meaning
yeah what's his uh what does he make of
death
oh i don't know and this is where it
would be nice
to uh have him here he has
you know from a distance criticized
our work as misguided having said that
though when we were together
he said something along the lines that
there is no
uh theoretical body of work
in academic psychology right now
for which there is more empirical
evidence
and so i appreciated that he's a great
uh
researcher he's a good clinician the
other thing that we will agree
to disagree about uh rather vociferously
um is ultimately
political slash um economics so i
remember being at dinner with him
telling him that the next book that i
wanted to write uh
was going to be called why left and
right or both beside the point
and my argument was going to be and it
is going to be that both liberal and
political no liberal and conservative
political philosophy
are each intellectually and morally
bankrupt because they're both framed in
terms of assumptions about human nature
that are demonstrably false
and jordan didn't mind me uh knocking
liberal political philosophy on those
grounds that would basically be like
stephen pinker's
blank slate but he took issue
when uh i pointed out that um
actually it's conservative political
philosophy which starts with john
locke's assumption that in a state of
nature there are no
societies just autonomous individuals
who are striving for survival
that's one of the most obviously
patently wrong assertions in the history
of intellectual thought and locke uses
that to justify
his claims about the individual right to
acquire
unlimited amounts of property which is
ultimately
uh the justification for neoliberal
economics and well can you look on a
little bit
uh what's the uh can you describe his
philosophy again
as view of the world sure and what uh
neoliberal economics is yeah let me
translate it in
english so basically on all
these days anybody who says i'm a i
i'm a conservative free market type
you're following john locke and adam
smith
whether you're aware of it or not so
here's john locke
who by the way all these guys are great
so for me to appear to criticize any of
these folks it is with the highest
regard
and also we need to understand in my
estimation
how important their ideas are lock is
working in a time
where all rule was top down by
divine right and he's trying desperately
to come up
with a philosophical justification to
shift
power and autonomy to
individuals and he starts in his second
treatise on government 1690 or so
he he just he says okay let's start with
a state of nature
and he's like in a state of nature
there's no societies
there's just individuals and
in a perfect universe there wouldn't be
any societies
there would just be individuals who by
the law
of nature have a right to survive
and uh in the service of survival
they have the right to acquire and
preserve
the fruits of their own labor
and but his point is and it's actually a
good one you know he's following hobbs
here
he's like well the problem with that is
that people are [ __ ]
and um if they would let each other
alone
then we would still be living in a state
of nature everybody
just doing what they did to get by each
day
but it's a whole lot easier you know if
i see like an
apple tree a mile away well i can go
over and
pick an apple but if you're 10 meters
away with an apple in your hand it's a
lot easier if i
pick up a rock and crack your head and
take the apple
and his point was that
the problem is that people can't be
counted on to behave
they will they will take each other's
property
moreover he argued
if someone takes your property you have
the right
uh to you have the right to retribution
in proportion to the degree of the
magnitude of the transgression
english translation if i take your apple
you have the right to take an apple back
you don't have the right to kill my
firstborn
but people being people they're apt to
escalate retaliatory behavior thus
creating
what lock called a state of war so he
said
in order to avoid a state of war people
reluctantly
give up their freedom in exchange for
security they agree to obey the law
and that the sole function of government
is to keep domestic tranquility and to
ward off
foreign invasion in order to protect
our right to property all right so now
here's the
property thing all right so uh uh
lock says if you look in the bible and
in nature there is no
private property and
but lock says well surely
you if there's anything that you own
it's your body
and surely you have a right by nature
to stay alive and then by extension
anything that you do where you exert
effort or
labor that becomes your private property
so back to the apple tree if i walk over
to an apple tree that's everybody's
apples
until i pick one and the minute i do
that is my
apple right and then he says you can
have as many apples as you want
as long as you don't waste them and as
long as you don't
impinge on somebody else's right
to get apples all right so far so good
yep
and then he says
well okay
in the early days you you could only eat
so many apples and or you could only
trade so many apples with somebody else
so he was like well if you put a fence
around
a bunch of apple trees those become your
apples that's your
property if somebody else wants to put a
fence around nebraska
that's their property
and everybody can have as much property
as they want
because the world is so big
that there is no limit to what you can
have
if you pursue it by virtue of your own
effort
but then he says money came into the
picture
and this is important because it's a he
noticed
long before anybody before the freud's
of the world
that money is funky because it has no
intrinsic value
he's like ooh look at that shiny piece
of metal
that actually has if you're hungry
and you have a choice between a carrot
and a lump of gold
in the desert most people are going to
go for the carrot
but his point is is that the allure of
money
is that it's basically a concentrated
symbol of wealth but because it doesn't
spoil
locke said you're entitled to have as
much money
as you're able to garner right
then he says well the reality is
is that some people are more
the word that he used was industrious he
said some people more
industrious than others all right today
we would say smarter
less lazy more ambitious he just said
that's
natural it's also true therefore he
argued
uh over time some people are going to
have
a whole lot of property and other people
not much
at all inequality for locke
is natural and beneficial
for everyone his argument was that you
know the rising tide lifts all
boats and that the truly creative and
innovative are entitled to relatively
unlimited worth because we're all better
off
as a result so the point very
simply is that well that's base and then
you have adam smith
the you know in the next century uh with
the invisible hand where adam smith says
everyone pursuing their own selfish
that's not necessarily pejorative
if everyone pursues their own selfish
interests
we will all be better off as a result
and what do you think is the flawed in
that way well there's two flaws one is
is that well one flaw
is first of all that that
it is based on an erroneous assumption
to begin with which is that there never
was a time in human history when we were
in
a social species in a sense you don't
feel like that we there's uh
this emphasis of uh individual autonomy
is a flawed premise like where there's a
there's something
fundamentally deeply uh interconnected
between us
i do i think that plato and socrates uh
you know in the crito were closer to the
truth
uh when they started with the assumption
that we were
interdependent and they derived
individual autonomy as a manifestation
of a functional social system
that's fascinating so when margaret
thatcher you're too young
you know in the 1980s she said societies
there's no such thing as societies
there's just
individuals pursuing their self-interest
so so that's one point where i would
take issue respectfully with john locke
point number two
is when locke says in 1690 well
england's filled up um
so if you want some land just go to
america it's empty
or maybe there's a few savages there
just kill them
so and melville does the same thing in
moby dick where he
he thinks about will there ever come a
time where we run
out of whales and he says no
but we have run out of whales and so
locke was right maybe in 1690 that the
world was large
and had infinite resources he's
certainly
wronged today in in my opinion
also wrong is the claim uh that
the unlimited pursuit of personal wealth
does not harm those around us
there is no doubt uh that radical
inequality
is tragic psychologically and physically
it's
poverty is not that terrible it's easy
for me to save because i have a place to
stay and something to eat
but as long as you're not starving and
and
have a place to be poverty is not as
challenging as being having the
impoverished and close proximity to
those who are
obscenely wealthy so the it's not the
any absolute measure
of your well-being it's the inequality
of that well-being is quite frantically
painful
um so maybe just to
link on the jordan peterson thing in
terms of your uh
disagreement on his world view so he
went through quite a bit
it you know there's been quite a bit of
fire right in
in his defense or maybe his opposition
of the idea of equality of outcomes
so looking at the inequality that's in
our world
looking at you know certain groups
measurably having an outcome that's
different than other groups
and then drawing conclusions about
fundamental
uh unfairness injustice inequality in
the system so like
systematic racism systematic sexism
systematic anything else that creates
inequality
and he's been kind of uh saying pretty
simple things
uh to say that uh you know the system
for the most part
is not broken or flawed yeah
that the inequalities part the um the
inequality
of outcomes is part of our world what we
should strive for is the uh
you know equality of opportunity yeah
and i i do not dispute that
as an abstraction but again to back up
for a second i
i do take issue with jordan's uh fervent
devotion
to the free market and his cavalier
dismissal of marxist ideas
which he has uh in my estimation
mischaracterized in his public
depictions
let's let's get into it so he he just
seems to really not like
um uh socialism marxism communism yeah
uh historically speaking sort of uh i
mean
how would i characterize it i'm not
exactly sure i don't want to again
yeah he'll eventually be here to defend
himself john locke unfortunately not
here to defend
exactly but what's what's your sense uh
about marxism and and um
the uh the way jordan talks about the
way you think about it
from the economics from the
philosophical perspective yeah well i i
if we were all here together i'd say we
need to start with marx's economic and
philosophical manuscripts of
1844 before marx became
more of a polemicist and i would argue
that
marx's political philosophy he's a
crappy economist i don't
dispute that but his arguments about
human nature
his arguments about the inevitably
catastrophic psychological and
environmental
and economic effects of capitalism i
would argue every one of those
has proven quite right marx maybe did
not
have the answer but he saw
in the 18 whenever he was
writing that inevitably
capitalism would lead to massive
inequity
that it was ultimately
based on the need to denigrate
and dehumanize labor to render them in
his language a fleshy cog
in a giant machine and that
it would create a tension and conflict
between those
who own things and those who made
things that over time would always you
know the thomas pickerty guy
who writes about capital and just makes
the point
that return on investment will always be
greater
than wages that means the people with
money
are going to have a lot more that means
there's going to come a point where the
economic house of cards
falls apart now the joseph shumpters of
the world they're like that's creative
destruction bring it that that's
great so i think it's niles ferguson he
was he's a historian he may be at
stanford now he was at harvard
you know he writes about the history of
money and he's like
yeah there's been 20 or whatever
depressions and big recessions
uh in the last several hundred years and
when that happens half of the population
or whatever
is catastrophically inconvenienced
but that's the price that we pay
for progress other people would argue
and i
would agree with them
that i will happily sacrifice
the rate of progress in order to flatten
the curve of economic destruction
to put that in plainer english um
i would um
direct our attention to the social
democracies
that forgetting for the moment of
whether it's possible
to do this on a scale in a country as
big as ours
on all of the things that really matter
you know gross domestic gdp or whatever
that's just an abstraction
but when you look at whatever the united
nations
says how we measure quality of life uh
you know life expectancy education
you know rates of alcoholism suicide
and so on the countries that do better
are the mixed economies they're market
economies
that have high tax rates in exchange
uh for the provision of
services that come as a right for
citizens
yeah so i mean i guess the question is
you've kind of mentioned that uh you
know uh like as marx described a
capitalism
with a slippery slope eventually things
go awry in some kind of way so that's
the question is when you have when you
implement a system yeah how does it go
wrong eventually
you know the you know eventually we'll
all be dead that's exactly right
no no look that's no that's right so
and then the criticism i mean i think
these days uh unfortunately marxism as
like
as a dirty word i i say unfortunately
because even if you
disagree with the philosophy
you should you should uh like calling
somebody a marxist
yeah should not be a thing that uh
shuts down all conversation no that's
right and and the fact is
i'm sympathetic with uh jordan's
dismissal of the folks and popular the
talking heads these days
who spew marxist words
um to me it's like fashionable nonsense
do you know that book that the physicist
wrote mocking
uh you're too young so in the uh 20 or
so years ago we're all pretty young
really yeah that's right but they're i
think they're with these nyu physicists
they wrote a paper just mocking the uh
kind of literary uh post-modern types
you know yes oh those kinds of yeah it
was just nonsense and of course it was
made the lead article
um and and you know my poor is marx
wouldn't be a marxist
[Laughter]
true i've read and listened to some of
the work of uh
richard wolff he speaks pretty
eloquently about marxism i like him
uh he's uh one of the only uh
you know one of the only people speaking
about a lot about marxism and the way we
are now
in in a serious way in and it's sort of
saying you know uh what are the flaws of
capitalism
not saying like yeah basically sounding
very different people should check out
his work
no there's all this kind of work this
kind of
outrage mob culture
of uh sort of demanding equality
equality of outcome
that's not marxism it is not marxism he
he didn't say that you know he literally
said each
what was it like each according to their
needs and each according to their
abilities or something like that
so the question is the implementation
like absolutely humans are messy so how
does it go
wrong like it does mat there you go
brilliant it's messy and this gets back
to my rant about
the book that i want to try if i don't
stroke out why left and right
are both beside the point you know the
the
people conservatives are
right when they condemn liberals
for being simple-minded by assuming that
a modification of external conditions
will yield
changes in human nature you know
you know again that's where marx and
skinner are odd bedfellows
you know here they are just saying oh
let's change the surroundings
and things will inevitably get better on
the other hand
when um conservatives
say that people are innately
selfish and they use that as the
justification
for glorifying uh the unbridled pursuit
of wealth
well they're only half right because it
turns out that
we can be innately selfish but we are
also
innately generous and reciprocating
creatures
there's remarkable studies i think
they've been done at yale
of you know babies 14 month old babies
um if someone hands them a toy and then
wants something
in return babies before they can walk
and talk
will reciprocate all right fine
if someone if they want a toy let's say
or
the bottle of water baby wants a bottle
of water
and i look like i'm trying to give it to
the baby
but i dropped the bottle so the baby
doesn't get what she or he wanted
when given a chance to reciprocate
little babies will reciprocate
because they're aware of and are
responding to intention
similarly if they see somebody
um behaving unfairly to to someone
they will not help that person in return
so so my point is is yeah we are
selfish creatures at times
but we are also simultaneously
uber social creatures who are
eager to reciprocate and in fact we're
congenitally prepared to be
reciprocators to the point where
uh we will reciprocate on the basis of
intentions
above and beyond what actually happened
how so
i mean your work is on the fundamental
role of the fear of mortality yeah
in ourselves how fundamental is this
reciprocation this human connection to
other humans
i think it's really innate yeah i think
it's because
yeah bats reciprocate uh not by
intention but
uh you know this i'm going here from
richard dawkins
uh the selfish gene you know to
i love the early dawkins i'm less
enamored
with the early beatles yeah no no again
i say this
with great respect but uh you know
dawkins
just points out that uh you know
reciprocation is
just fundamental cooperation is
fundamental you know it is the the it's
a one-sided view
of evolutionary takes on thanks when we
see it solely in terms of individual
competition
it's it's almost from a game theoretic
perspective too it's just easier to see
the world that way
it's it's easier to i don't know i i
mean
you see this in physics there's a whole
field of folks
like complexity yeah that kind of
embrace the fact that
it's all an intricately connected mess
and it's just
very difficult to do anything with that
kind of science
but it seems to be much closer to
actually representing what the world is
like
so like you put it earlier lex it's
messy
you